whether it's for real or whether it's
fake you have to have confidence because
human beings are they don't be led by
somebody who's like oh God I don't know
what do you guys think you know they
want somebody who's going to
definitively say here's what we're going
to do and this is going to be righteous
and God-fearing and that's the way it
has to be and
so when you when you go when you go to a
crew you turn to 90 people
you know and and you have all these
faces sort of looking at you like what
do you want to do next which is a
terrifying thing it takes you 10 or 15
years to get comfortable enough to just
go dude it's my way of the highway you
know you you have to you have to be able
to do that I mean it's probably it
wasn't until I was 40 that I could kind
of go here's what we're doing here's
exactly what we're doing here's all I
want and and and mean it and people
would sort of go right away